[موسيقى]
قميص ارجنتيني مستوح من البشت وشاكيرا
تهرب من بيكا الى الصحراء وجورجينا تهدر
رونالدو
اهلا بكم
في خبر تفعل معه رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي كلاسيما العرب انتشرت صور لقميص
منتخب الارجنتين مستوحه من البشت العربي
الذي ارتديه ميسي في حفل تتويج بكاس
العالم يقال ان اديداس بصدد عمل عده نسخ
المال تخليدا للمناسبات وكان قميص
الارجنتين الازرق الذي يحمل الرقم 10
نافذه بالكامل من محلات بيع اديداس حول
العالم عقبه تتويج منتخب التانجو بلقب
مونديال
[موسيقى]
بمناسبه الاحتفال بعيد الميلاد قدمت
جورجينا رودريغيز شركه كريستيانو رونالدو
هديه سخيه للنجم البرتغالي حيث اشترت له
سياره رولز رويس بقيمه 300 الف دولار فقط
يذكر بان رونالدو يجري حاليا محادثات مع
نادي النصر السعودي في صفقه التاريخيه تصل
قيمتها الى 175 مليون جنيه
[موسيقى]
تعيش النجمه العالميه شاكيرا فتره اعياد
مختلفه مع نهايه العام الذي شهد انفصالها
عن نجم الكره الاسباني
[موسيقى]
على حسابها في انستغرام في الصحراء تبحث
عن الهدوء في عيد الميلاد كي تحصد الصوره
ثلاثه ملايين اعجاب اكثر
بوجود نخبه من نجوم الرياضه المصريه احتفل
حارس مرمى منتخب مصر السابق عصام الحضري
بزفاف ابنه شهد ونشر الحضري تغريده كتب
فيها مش عارف اوصف احساسي فرحان بيكي
وزعلان في نفس الوقت انك خرجتي منيتي
[موسيقى]